foreign
everyone if you'd please join me in rise
for the Pledge of Allegiance
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
okay it's my church here
foreign
public hearing on Senate Bill 58
and all the prime sponsor to introduce
it
I have to excuse me I'm sure to clerk
today so
uh good morning
my name is James Gray I represent Senate
District Six and I'm here to introduce
Senate bill 58.
Senate Bill 58 has a very long past
unfortunately
we introduced the bill
many years ago
we started off with the state hospital
I had a constituent of mine that was
injured quite severely in the state
hospital
she was working there
out for many weeks
uh we made some changes to the state
hospital
the hospital Association came to us a
year or so later and says well we need
some help also
where are we now uh last information
that I got was that there were 50
assaults
in medical
institutions here in January 50.
why do I care well we had a guard at the
Rochester
facility frisbee Memorial Hospital
who's killed
this was subject of a committee
committee said well do this do this do
this the first few things had to do with
escalation and de-escalation techniques
that was also packaged with some of the
language similar to what you see here
when it came over to the house it says
well gee that would be two different
committees we don't want to deal with
that they because of time they stripped
out the portion that you see here
past the de-escalation techniques Etc
and now we're back again
uh in the Senate uh because of uh press
that we received uh about putting this
into the warrantless arrest statute we
went and looked for a different place to
put it
legislature a long time ago recognized
that certain merchants and movie theater
people deserve some special
consideration
we believe that the people that working
in the hospitals or a patient comes in
has a life-threatening situation
they can't just walk away from a patient
whether that patient is belligerent or
not
um so in here
uh and and the hospitals aren't in full
support of putting it in here instead of
the and I'm sure that they will say that
unless they've changed their mind and I
don't believe they have
uh but this gives them the right to
detain the people this gives the officer
you know based on the evidence that he
sees when he gets there to do certain
things just as uh if a person is uh
taking things at a store or recording a
movie uh at a movie theater
they can do that same kind of thing it's
very limited in what they can do
many of these because the people will
either be uh have mental health issues
or they will be suffering from drugs or
they will be
any number of conditions these things
will probably never get prosecuted
but we need to resolve the situation we
need our health care workers to be able
to work going to work and coming home
from work every day without being
assaulted so we appreciate the
consideration of the bill I believe it
is a good bill it will serve the state
of New Hampshire well thank you
any questions for the senator
representative
name
Muse yes
thank you it has been a week
but um one of the things that I'm
curious about Senator are
um
how these incidents evolve in hospitals
so you've testified that there are 50
assaults
what's happening what's going on in our
hospitals
that's basically leading to hospitals
becoming places of violence
I can tell you that in the testimony
that before the committee and the
commission a lot of it had to do with as
I said mental health issues and or
drug-related issues
okay and again if if the person does not
and I'm going to put air quotes around
this require the treatment they can ask
the person to leave
okay and if they don't leave the police
can come in and arrest them the problem
comes in is when they've got a
life-threatening condition that the
hospital has to treat
and they're caught between a rock and a
hard place somebody who says I'm going
to stab you I'm going to hit you I'm
going to whatever
but they can't walk away from that
person
50 assaults
in January is what I was told
and personally I believe that there's a
lot of minor results that go unreported
so you know further questions thank you
Senator thank you
and the chair calls uh Senator Cindy
Rosenwald
thank you very much Mr chairman for the
record I'm Cindy Rose from well that
represents Senate District 13 which is
much of Nashua and I have longer written
testimony which you all have so I'm not
going to read it but I'm here as a
co-sponsor of this bill to ask you
to please reject it in its current form
and return it to the thoughtful
compromise approach that was worked on
for much of last year and agreed to by a
disparate group of stakeholders this
disparate group of stakeholders that
came together to agree on language
included Nami
the disability rights Center law
enforcement the ACLU and the hospitals
the reason all of these groups agreed on
the original language of Senate Bill 58
was that it provided Clarity to law
enforcement around their ability to
execute a warrantless arrest for a
potential misdemeanor for violence in
certain Health Care settings but
importantly did so without
criminalizing mental illness
unfortunately the Senate passed version
of this bill will further criminalize
mental illness by removing important
limitations in current law
therefore broadening the potential for
someone suffering from mental illness to
be arrested these are patients seeking
health care but the bill will make it
more likely they'll end up in jail and
definitely not get treatment for their
illness
there have also subsequent to the Senate
actions on this bill been questions
raised as to whether the detainment and
Restraint of patients would violate
standards of the centers for Medicare
and Medicaid services and risk a
Hospital's certification and funding
from these important payers for all
these reasons I asked the committee not
to pass the bill in its current form but
to consider adopting the original
version with the clarifying language
around medical necessity that I've
attached to my letter to you all and I
thank you for the opportunity to be here
I'm happy to answer questions
thank you Senator could you tell us what
the impetus was for the big flip what
caused that change
I think there were
well I'm guessing
hearsay
there was a senator who didn't like it
and
then things snowballed from there last
year this original version was passed
unanimously by the Senate and sent over
to the house whereas Senator grades had
it got
carved out of something else that was
passed so
I was not privy to those discussions but
I was part of the negotiating group that
came to this agreement among all these
different stakeholders
any further questions for the senator
representative Newman
I just have a question about the the
amendment what what effect will it have
on the bill that we have in front of us
as amended I see it amends one of the
amends a law in in that particular
paragraph C is not in the amended
version of the Senate I'm just wondering
how that all will work together so it
would not
but if you were to
adopt as an amendment the original
language of Senate Bill 58 as introduced
this year I would ask you to include
this amendment which
changes just one small part to make it
clear that it's not law enforcement who
would be determining
what medical treatment is necessary but
it would be the Judgment of the licensed
health care professional thank you
so you know for the question thank you
very much
chair calls
Margaret Reed
room sorry
yeah I hate that I like this better
I think so
good morning my name is Margaret W Brew
I am a registered nurse
I'm testifying in support of this bill
the provision for warrantless arrest was
removed from Senate Bill 459 FN this
decision afforded the opportunity for
the bill to pass and be signed by
governor sununu on July 22nd of 2022.
in removing it it negated an opportunity
to effectively support Health Care
employees who are impacted by workplace
violence
in an article by Chapin and caller in
in healthcare or Social Service settings
workplace violence effects it involves
employees clients patients customers
consumers and visitors
workplace violence costs the United
States
151 billion dollars per year
with an average of 250
000 per incident
these figures do not capture the hidden
costs of workplace violence
those are emotional pain depression
isolation and anxiety
in turn this has a direct impact on the
ability of the Health Care Organization
to meet patient needs and Industry
accreditation standards
it directly impacts the fiscal stability
of the state of New Hampshire's
healthcare industry
the following events that occurred in
New Hampshire hospital facilities are
cited
hospital security guards were summoned
to the Intensive Care Unit by an RN to
move family members who were physically
fighting the fight was about which
daughter was going to get their dying
mother's jewelry
one guard was injured by the family
members and required emergency
department care
their supervisor cited that injury is
quote part of the job
the injured guard returned to work until
being harmed again and then resigned
an intensive care nurse
was threatened by a patient who stated
that upon discharge they would surge out
the nurse and kill them
the patient had threatened to harm
emergency department staff during prior
admissions
no reports were filed by the emergency
department staff as they believe nothing
would change
when the ICU report RN reported the
event it was dismissed as hearsay
as there were no witnesses to the event
the RN resigned
a surgeon performing a technically
challenging procedure at a patient's
bedside
the surgeon became enraged due to a
malfunctioning surgical instrument
the surgeon through the blood-covered
instrument at the RN assisting the
procedure
the patient had Hepatitis B and AIDS
the nurse reported the event to the unit
manager and the manager said well it's a
good thing that you ducked
this surgeon was not addressed about his
actions in the event
the RN resigned
the staff involved in these situations
perceived there was no recourse other
than resignation due to the harmful
situations they were involved in
the organization did not support the
employee employee nor effectively
address the situation
warrantless arrests would be integrated
into the organizational's comprehensive
workplace violence management plan
effectively applying the warrantless
arrest law would afford the Health Care
System the ability to support those who
are affected by violence
workplace safety is inextricably
connected to patient safety and directly
affects patient outcomes
workplace violence has a direct effect
on employee engagement morale
Recruitment and Retention of staff
violence negatively affects the
socioeconomics of all New Hampshire
communities
the passing of Senate Bill 58 will
positively impact those affected by
violence in the health care industry
thank you
let's see yep representative guy stay
like thank you very much
um I just want to clarify
um it seems that you part of your
testimony was about assault by a surgeon
against a nurse
um but the bill talks about people in
the care of
the medical professionals not the people
performing the medical procedures and so
um just wondering maybe I'm
misunderstanding but I don't see how
this would address that particular
circumstance
my point was that we are not only
looking the the concern we have and I
have specifically is that we're somehow
trying to pin bad behavior on the
mentally ill
it isn't that's why I use that example
the bad behavior is across the board it
is visitors it is family it is
co-workers whether or not they have a
specific diagnosis these are the people
we're harming each other in the
profession the families are coming in
and harming us so my example is that
warrantless arrest is not just about
arresting the mentally ill or arresting
the patients we need to be considerate
of the whole circumstance that promotes
violence in health care and we need to
be concerned about all aspects of it
thank you
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
so did the hospital have the option to
to take some kind of disciplinary action
and they just chose not to yes okay
see no further questions thank you very
much for your testimony
she recognizes Mark Grossman
hello I'm Mark Grossman I'm an Emergency
Physician
um
I hate to say it over 20 years of
experience in emergency medicine and I
currently work at the Portsmouth
Regional hospital and some other
hospitals in New Hampshire I've been in
New Hampshire since 2018 I came from
Florida
um and what I'll tell you is that the
importance of health care workers safety
is
[Music]
um
I would say take it more seriously in
Florida
where I was assaulted by a patient and I
called the police and they came
interviewed me interviewed Witnesses and
they removed the patient immediately
and I was surprised and disappointed
when I moved up here
that the same safety
is not afforded to us in the state and
uh I was a victim of an assault while I
was up here and the police came and they
said first that um well we didn't see it
so we can't do anything despite the fact
that there are videotapes and Witnesses
and then another time when there was an
assault and the police were there I said
well you've seen it now
can you arrest them and they said no
because deadly force wasn't used
um so I think there's several aspects to
this one of them is that the laws don't
really protect the health care worker
and what they tell us is well it's only
a misdemeanor so if we remove them we
still would have to bring them back to
be cleared once we bring them to jail so
we bring them back to the emergency room
um the other thing that happens is they
will the police
will sort of victim shame and say are
you sure you want to testify in front of
a jury
that you've been assaulted and you have
to give your home address and things
like that and I've seen this happen I've
seen it across different jurisdictions
and it's very disheartening to hear that
and to have people discourage from
pressing charges and from testifying not
even given the chance
and but I believe this bill will do
is give us some peace of mind that when
we come to work
if we do get assaulted and it's not a
mental health issue I mean there are
patients with mental health issues that
are involved with us but I see it more
often than not
uh non-mental Health cases sometimes
it's people who are desperate and have
nothing to lose
people who are addicted to drugs people
that are expecting something that
they're not getting
um and sometimes it's people that are
alcoholic but sometimes especially post
pandemic it's people that are just
enraged with the weights in the
emergency department waiting to go
upstairs to get a bed
um overcrowding and just a lack of staff
so they have to wait for lab results or
CAT scan results or how come you're not
taking care of my mother
um and they will get very upset and will
get physically violent
we're protected by security guards not
by police who are armed and sworn
officers and those security guards
don't have a sworn duty to act if they
sense a danger they may try to help and
intervene
if they are overpowered they will step
back and call for the police and we have
to wait for the police to come
I truly believe that we need to
strengthen the um
the protections of health care workers
we're having problems with recruit
recruitment retention of health care
workers because they know that if they
come to New Hampshire to work they
aren't protected and I've spoken to
people that have left the state of New
Hampshire to go work in other states
where they are protected after they have
been assaulted or if they've been a
witness to an assault and this is very
concerning and I'm very hopeful that
this bill will help strengthen
our protections and keep us safer in the
emergency department I want to remind
everybody that three years ago we were
celebrating healthcare workers as Heroes
for staying and taking care of patients
that were
communicable and ill and putting our own
lives at risk and we still put our own
lives at risk every single day and this
is one bill that will help so we don't
have to worry about at least this aspect
of our of our work
representative Muse
thank you for taking my question I I
just wanted to drill into your statement
that that health care workers are
unprotected in New Hampshire
my understanding is healthcare workers
are protected by the same laws against
assault that the rest of us are
are protected by so so what a what I'm
not understanding is how
um
is is exactly you know how or why you
think that that hospital workers
are less protected and I guess the other
thing I'm struggling to understand is if
there if there is an issue with violence
uh in in hospital settings it has a
hospital Administration actually had
conversations with local police
departments about responses and
um and and maybe treating incidents at
hospitals a little bit differently
sure so
keep in mind that a hospital especially
an emergency room
has a different clientele and a
different sense of Acuity than a local
Diner or any other business
and we're dealing with people that are
sick and that are frustrated and it's
they're concentrated in one place so
the violence is probably more likely
because it's there are volatile
situations every day and there are
disagreements about treatment and people
come in and after having consulted
Google they expect that the treatment is
going to be X Y and Z and when they're
not getting X Y and Z they may get upset
and I see this every day every single
shift
and once again post pandemic they can't
get in to see their primary care doctor
their surgery has been postponed some
people have lost their insurance because
they're not working or they're
underemployed so they get frustrated
because they can't afford their
medication or they come in sicker
because they can't follow up with
primary care and they've lost access to
care
in regards to your second query
we meet with police on a regular basis
the police aren't staffed
to protect our department they will
prioritize a response to the emergency
room to a call for help
and as we all know from watching TV some
of these events may be over in seconds
or minutes
by the time they get there even if they
have a five minute response which would
be great
the incident may be completed whatever
that is
so we'll try to deal with it the best we
can
and without the police presence and once
they arrive it makes it easier
now again once the police do get there
if we have this volatile situation where
somebody has tried to attack us
and the police can't then remove the
patient
the volatility remains
and that's
sort of answer to be to your question
you can really ask that question but
that's where this law would help protect
us so once they do respond
they can't really do anything right now
they will say it's a misdemeanor they
didn't witness it and they won't remove
person and question that you sound
and that's what we really need them to
do
it's not criminalizing mental health by
the way it's simply protecting us
could you from a doctor from a from a
practical standpoint
you're treating someone in the hospital
for whatever injury he becomes violent
disruptive
the police come this law is passed he
can be arrested
but the treatment has to continue
somewhere
can you walk us through what what would
that look like they can't take him away
because he has to be treated
I'm inferring from what you said earlier
that they would just take them right
away where would they bring them so
that's um
that would be honestly on a case-by-case
basis if it's a family member for
example somebody that's not seeking
treatment they just happen to be on
campus obviously they can be taken away
without delay
if it's somebody that needs to be
admitted to the hospital or is being
treated and needs to be in the emergency
department for that treatment for X
number of hours
I would say that either the police would
stay there and they would have them in
custody and remove them once they're
cleared medically
or they would
they would have to come back or you know
the deputy sheriff would come or
something along those lines from
Corrections then they would still be in
custody while being treated
as a follow-up and if they're admitted
it's the same we we've had prisoners who
are admitted to the hospital and they
have a guard that's staying with them
just to make sure that
everybody is safe including the patient
and I agree the patient may be
vulnerable as well
and they do deserve treatment and I'm
not saying that they don't deserve
treatment
if they can be cleared and removed and
it's safe then I would advocate for that
if not then we still need our protection
and what I've seen in other states that
I've worked in over the years
that's if they're arrested they get
arraigned or whatever it is then
Corrections will stay with them a
corrections officer
or a sheriff's deputy in the state
thank you representative Amanda Purdy
thank you Mr chair thank you doctor for
taking my question I have two part
questions one is you you know describe
the whole scenario Workforce shortage
not just at the hospital at the police
at you know entire
uh community in in different forms
that's affecting the response the
emergency crisis response
and how does this impact if the
communities have
um crisis mobile crisis
um
units and
has that alleviated some of the flash
points at the emergency room if the
crisis is interwined before the patient
or before the person gets to the
emergency room deflated
I of course I and I'm actually a huge
proponent of this I although I don't
believe it's completely rolled out in
the state it's something that's
relatively new
I'm excited to see it and I think uh the
de-escalation of these cases before they
come to the emergency department is
vital
and it's been effective and I think our
psychiatric holds in the emergency
department are down but they're still
there
and I don't think every Community is as
well served
as they deserve to be within the state
of New Hampshire but again this is
something that I believe is a work in
progress and I'm looking forward to its
full implementation
thank you so there are
tools that's available but not
completely implemented
so
from your perspective as a provider this
is another tool in the toolbox to
de-escalate and provide a safe
environment for everybody to provide a
patient family everybody yes I I agree
because the emergency department
probably isn't the best place for
somebody who's having a mental health
crisis
um and again I want to reiterate that
that's not necessarily the patience I'm
talking about that are perpetrating
these assaults
um but they may trigger other people so
if they're in the hallway waiting and
they sort of start getting
agitated
frustrated what have you that made and
I've seen this it becomes sort of a
domino effect where other people around
them get frustrated and upset and they
see well this person's getting so much
attention and I'm not
so I've seen that as well but again to
answer your question I I believe that
this is something that will benefit us
benefit everybody in the end
representative
so I'm sitting here wondering and I hear
it's because it's only a misdemeanor
they can't do anything
so in my head I'm thinking we need to
raise the level of this assault on a
health care worker
so that they can do something
it goes up to a felony then they can
take them all right and that and that
would mirror other states laws
yeah uh and just for clarity I'm an EMT
work for a fire department uh
one of my Crews was just involved in the
melee at a hospital
and that it almost got his nose broken
while trying to protect a nurse from uh
someone who is intoxicated so I'm well
aware
and I do believe we need to do something
and not just a little feel-good thing
something that actually protects our
healthcare workers
so do you think we should raise this is
my question because I know he was going
to ask if there was a question in there
yeah
I think that whatever
laws need to change
I can't tell you what the penalties
should be or what the category of crime
whether it's felonious or misdemeanor
but I think whatever it needs to be to
have these
assailants removed
that's how you should Define it I can't
say again whether it's a felony or
misdemeanor but it should be the level
that somebody's removed
I got that
thank you for your testimony doctor
oh representative breeds here okay
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question as far as Healthcare uh the
hospital administrators do you find that
they sometimes are a roadblock to
calling for police help and it's and if
that if they do frown on that and make
it you know
something they don't encourage do you
think that something should be added as
a protection against for for health care
workers who have called the police I I
don't believe so I I at my hospital our
Administration has been very supportive
of of protecting us
again they have no role in the
enforcement of the laws
um so but they would never say to us
well don't call the police or don't
testify or don't press charges because
it's in their best interest to keep
their workers safe and keep the patients
safe and keep it a healthy working
environment
thank you also one of my ministers is
right behind me Sarah so
act natural
nice answer then thank you for your time
thank you Josh the chair recognizes Josh
Henry
Jason
good morning everybody uh Jason Henry
superintendent of Rockingham County Jail
so I'm just going to give you some
I want to give the end result if a bill
like this goes into effect
so I agree healthcare workers getting
assaulted is is horrible I have
healthcare workers inside my own jail I
get assaulted it's
it is difficult I have over 50 of my
inmates are on some sort of psychotropic
medication the rate of violence has gone
up tremendously over the past couple
years
um we have seen more in-house
um psychiatric patients
that have been charged with some sort of
assault I have people that are iea
status and voluntary
um you know emergency admissions sitting
inside of my jail
because they're a mental health crisis
and severe month Health crisis it may
have salted a staff member at one of the
hospitals and they send to jail
now at the jail we're not equipped to do
four-point restraints we cannot force we
do medication
I am concrete and steel
and it's not a place for somebody to
mental health so I think a couple things
in this law one I hear somebody who's
not in mental health distress or crisis
I get that
that's the person you arrest and I agree
that there is laws about there for being
assaulted if you want to enhance the
penalties maybe on a on the First
Responders and the um workers of the
hospital that might make sense but the
laws are out there for if you're
assaulted
I am very concerned about those in
Mental Health crisis I testified in this
bill in 2021 when it came out gain the
end result if somebody's in Mental
Health crisis why are we sending to the
jail I in turn when they get to us they
need a higher level of care than the
jail can give now we have some medical
staff and those kinds of things but in
turn we bring them back to the Geo to
the hospital the same place they
probably assaulted somebody and they're
very angry with us because we brought
them back
and just because I have a officer there
doesn't necessarily mean they're going
to be able to stop another assault
they're there in proximity because they
still have to stay out of the way
because a person's getting care so that
does not solve this issue okay they're
still going to get charged either way so
you're bringing them it's somebody who's
in the middle of getting care to a jail
to bring back to get care okay so we're
interrupting the care so I think that's
counterproductive of what we're trying
to again Mental Health crisis somebody
that's actually in Mental Health crisis
so I think we need to separate the two
uh somehow some way because there's a
big difference with there
um
so I also heard out here
congregate settings basically you have
shelters that have the same issue a
bunch of people that are angry and stuff
like that and they get assaulted you
take this to the next level and they
also get a higher level if they're
assaulted I understand hospitals don't
they're not equipped to keep these
people there
neither are the jails but the state of
New Hampshire has been in a fight back
and forth and has been determined that
something needs to be done for the
mental illness and my humble opinion is
to be more in brick and mortar someplace
to bring them to and that's probably a
lot of other states you have is some
place that specializes to bring them to
not just a
County facility where they all go to
where we have limited staff limited
resources because it's a short-term
turnaround they're designed for
pre-trial and a few sentence it sends
less than a year the reason why you get
sentenced standing over a year State
Prison has a lot more resources than a
county does so Michael's only concern
releases what are we doing with the
people in Mental Health crisis and I do
believe that we will be arresting our
way and putting into jail somebody to
Mental Health crisis
thank you
what is your Staffing like I mean do you
have the ability the staff to be able to
to have
um example you know officers arrest
somebody and they have to go back and
they
um I mean I guess you wouldn't get
involved until they were held after a
bail determination was made correct
right after the rest is made some sort
of bail put on correct no bail or
whatever bail whatever happens then we
would then they become our ours and
whether I have Staffing or not if they
have to go back I have to send some
money and like we are 35 Staff members
short
um state prisons over 100 plus short
we're all short yeah but it doesn't make
a difference we would have to go back
but it doesn't necessarily preclude
that's going to stop from being
assaulted again again we're in proximity
and it's happened multiple times even an
ambulances unfortunately we're in the
back of the ambulance and the patient
who's in severe mental health crisis
they could do all kinds of stuff
assaults person and ambulance right but
they don't turn back around
and bring them back to the jail right
right they take him to the hospital who
has
the care of things that they can do that
frankly I cannot at a jail so that's my
concern those are in Mental Health
crisis
representative means pretty
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question the same question I ask you
about de-escalation how is that protocol
helpful in reducing the
crisis mental health or dual diagnosis
crisis de-escalation is the first step
and how are we doing in terms of the
state and how would it impact
if this law is passed or not passed
so this law doesn't
really affect my de-escalation because I
this would be arrested and come to me
jails in general that is huge what we do
is de-escalation we train so much in
de-escalation because we are there
within 24 hours a day seven days a week
so we do not like to get wrestling
matches or have to report so we do a lot
of de-escalation uh my previous life I
was a full-time police officer okay so
then I moved into Corrections there's
still a lot of work and good work being
done out there in de-escalation on the
streets but uh with the Acuity that is
out there it is tough to de-escalate all
these situations we're getting I think
in law enforcement General and people in
general are getting better uh but with
this bill in general for us it is
already out of basically our hands
you're arresting and bringing to us and
we have to figure out
what we can or cannot help this person
with
representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so in your opinion
the end effect of a bill like this would
be the Rockingham County Jail could see
an increase of mental health patients an
exponential increase of mental health
patients and one that you may not be
able to
sufficiently take on
we've seen a huge increase just over the
past couple of years so we her lack of
capacity to take on that we have to deal
with I've been in Corrections over 20
plus years this has been a trend going
this way I was Merrimack County for
years and I will say the state hospital
here when somebody would assault
somebody they would send them to us and
I knew the person that ran and called
them you know God was well
they may have had a moment of brevity
basically they need a break too so they
sent into US knowing that there's gonna
be no culpable state of mind they're not
going to get convicted again I'm talking
people Mental Health crisis they're
you're gonna charge a big charge but not
ten times it gets dropped because they
have some sort of mental illness that no
culpable State of Mind
and again yes it gets them out of the
hair somewhere else to somewhere else is
a jail because there is no other
alternative right now until some other
things are built or staffed or other
things
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so we are hearing
right two very different sides of the of
the same story
so my question is when we heard from the
ER doctor
that when they called and they said well
we didn't witness this sorry and then
the other example was well it wasn't
if I'm remembering correctly a deadly
threat I think so can you explain
how is that handled so what what do you
do
well I can't spot I mean I could try to
speak to it but again just for those
foreign police officer but that is on
the police end two things one if it's a
class if it's a Class A misdemeanor that
is that is offense that you can go to
jail for so it's a restable it's a
restful fence and go to jail
um so it doesn't have to be necessary to
be a felony one two a warrantless arrest
for me personally looking at is you know
you have for domestic violence and a few
other ones because within that time
frame that they're going to go out and
significantly hurt the person the the
imminent danger imminent flight those
kinds of things so warrantless arrest if
you open that up for me what does it
stop where does it stop there for this
arrest like you said we have laws
protect each other if I if I can now say
I was assaulted and my friend saw me get
assaulted and now the police can just
arrest them because the warrantless
arrest
I get very nervous about that I do think
it will increase
um the jails I think it'll also be very
difficult for police officers because
you're going to see their volume go up
and again I heard in here that while a
police can arrest them and stay with
them they won't stay with them it's not
going to happen this goes through
they're going to arrest them
bring them to jail
because they're not going to stay unless
you're gonna put some sort of Bill they
have to stay because they don't have the
manpower to do it so they're going to
bring it to us why they're in crisis
mode probably could be wrestling could
get further injury or anything else
again
to us
back to the hospital
and now I sympathize the hospital
there's no we there's no winning with
this
representative Cameron
thank you Mr chairman thank you
superintendent for taking my question
um I'm going back to to my recollection
this bill says that it would be lawful
for a health care provider or his agent
to detain a person that has committed
one of these acts
until a peace officer can come and take
them away
how much time do you spend
initially for uh somebody new to the job
and annually on reasonable Force
for us reasonable Force so uh first we
have the academy which in there it's at
least an eight-hour training and four
Corrections at least you have to do 35
hours of training a year and use of
force is one of those trainings for us
that is done every single year
yeah
do you think that it would be extremely
important for the health care provider
or his agent to have that same training
so that a person is not having
unnecessary Force used on them to detain
them for the peace officer absolutely
anybody should have the training because
again
representative salik thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question how
many hospitals are in your District
like four or five in Rockingham County
so there's quite I mean there's small
hospitals larger hospitals so but our
designated receiving facilities Exeter
so they see the bulk of all of our stuff
okay and the way that I read this it
would be any medical setting so that
would include all the convenient care
places and urgent cares and whatnot so
if they were all saying you need to
provide this do you have anywhere close
to the capacity to manage any of this
no but
and two different things if it's
somebody that's not a mental health
crisis yes that's what we're designed
for we're designed as a jail for
somebody that has broken the law that we
have to deal with until they can go to
court or whatever if something's a
mental health crisis then the answer is
no we I am over capacity now of what we
have inside of there people waiting for
beds at the state hospital or number 21
in the queue I have people going to spew
I'm opening up extra units
specifically for mental health I just
hired another I'm adding 26 extra more
hours before mental health the explosion
of mental health is across the board
everywhere and so the end result is we
see a lot of it in the jails and a huge
increase of people being arrested and
then we still dealing with them and what
what can we do with them so if those
places all had the ability to do this
I'm not sure what's going to happen but
the treatment would not be where I would
feel comfortable of the for the patient
or individual
representative Muse
thank you for taking my question can you
just give us a quick overview of what
kind of of help or assistance you
actually get to this from the state uh
when you have uh prisoners who are in
Mental Health crisis so is any type of
support available at all or are you just
expected to wear how these folks
Warehouse these folks until their Trials
come up uh or they're released
help from the state uh little from the
county so the counties we support
everything it's all our budget like I
have full-time mental health people I
have clinicians and case managers
everything else if somebody has to go to
the Hampshire hospital then we have
paper we have to do we have petitions
all kinds of things we have to run
through to get them up to there uh then
if they can get there which again like I
have somebody else 21 in a queue I
thought people wait for months like the
hospitals do to get to the state
hospital and they turn around and
stabilize them within two days I don't
know how but anyways and they come back
to us
um and then for sbu the state prison
that's far and few between we signed up
there and that's a really high Acuity
case that needs to be in inside of there
but uh for the counties itself no it's
our it's your local County dollars and
whatever they can afford to have inside
facilities so each facility is a little
different
of how much they have to offer these
people that are a mental health crisis
some have more some have less
um depending on again what you can
afford
specifically what what kind of resources
do you have uh to support these people
right now
up in Rockingham County I I have a
full-time mental health person on staff
I have a license now called drug
counselor I have two case managers I
have another through what we we um
contract what's called Prime care it's
our medical they have a mental health
provider we have they have doctors there
on they come in every week twice a week
at least we have 24-hour Medical Care
with our nurses
so we have a pretty robust we're the
second entire country for County
facilities they have our own opioid
treatment program but then you take it
to another facility a lot of the
facilities are not 24-hour care so
there's no nurses on it the middle of
the night they don't have the mental
health might be a person that's
part-time
okay because they just that's all they
have so you're running the game at
Rockingham County where I'm at now it's
the third jail I've been at okay I was
at Carroll County before very small a
very limited budget limited what I had
up there to where I have very very
robust of what I have now
so it's really all over the map
depending on
which jelly wrap
representative Newman
I just have a quick question you put it
you're on a pretty bright line between
people that are a mental health crisis
and in in those that are not that either
one of those could cause a disturbance
and just in my reading in the bill and
it appears to me we'll probably talk
more about this in executive session is
that the bill itself does it says detain
any person I I'm do you think that that
bright line distinction between those
two types of people is important in this
case I I do because someone who's in a
mental health crisis needs a higher
level of care than what a jail can
support again let's go back to the
medications that I cannot cannot do
there's a lot of things and it's
concrete and steel it was not built for
knowledge is built forward to for mental
health patients and that's what they are
they're patients if they're in crisis
and their patients
in my mind that's what they need to be
need to be taken care of so I do think
there should be a line that is distinct
and how you want to find that and
however you want to clear them because
the 2021 if everyone goes back to that
there was a part of the bill that said
that it had to be cleared
um from their Mental Health crisis but
it was never defined who cleared it I
asked was the chiefs of police they said
no I asked if it's a jail no it's the
hospital that wants some no offense
hospital they want them out of there
it's our best interest to get them out
and then I bring them back and then I
have mental health people on to say well
wait why are they here and I can tell
you
just this week I have one from a
hospital has been released twice came
back to us and is a mess I'll take one
level further Mental Health crisis I
just went in at 1 30 this morning for
somebody who passed away because their
meth Health crisis and drugs
didn't belong with me but they're no
longer here on Earth
okay so this is what we're dealing with
thank you for your testimony
chair calls um Paula menahan
thank you um if you would indulge could
I have John Patty join me thank you
he has a card yep
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Paula minihan
Senior vice president state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all our
hospitals with me today is John Patty
executive director of support services
at Catholic Medical Center in Manchester
I will not um read my testimony you I am
it is being passed out we are in strong
support of 58.
um excuse me Senate Bill 58 and we do
appreciate Senator Grace support and
sponsorship of this bill as you have
heard there is a big change in this bill
which got changed on the senate floor we
support the concept of Senate Bill 58
and I have communicated with a number of
you in the past week or so
Regarding why this isn't so important in
the the history of this
um and I will um I am not going to take
a lot of your time because it is more
important that you hear from those that
actually have experienced this and and
witness it every day including um Mr
Patty who will speak in a moment all I
need to say is I think some testimony
unfortunately is conflating issues this
is not um intended to criminalize
Behavioral Health this is really a tool
as um as the representative indicated
this is a tool for law enforcement they
need this they are not here to testify
but they do not have and again Mr Patty
will talk about this in a minute they
don't have the they believe the
authority at this time law enforcement
to come in and arrest someone without a
warrant we do not support enhanced
penalties
um and there are reasons for that I know
other states have done that
unfortunately my colleagues have
indicated throughout the country
it um they don't it doesn't work um and
so we this is the approach that we are
taking and other states actually have
adopted our approach
um I know there are at least two other
states that are trying to get a similar
bill as introduced past because enhanced
penalties for some of these offenses
just will not work and and as indicated
by others these are Health Care
Professionals that want to care for
patients that's why they went into the
profession
they do not want a felony on someone's
record
um and that because that is a pretty
significant
um offense as you as you're aware so uh
let me just see here um we are happy to
work with the committee and I again I
have stated that to many of you that we
want to get a we believe that it is
important that we pass something that
ensures that health care workers are
protected when they are assaulted while
they are performing their work we owe it
to them to ensure that we provide law
enforcement with enough with another
tool that um they can have when they are
called to the hospital to respond to an
incident without the ability to arrest
without a warrant for misdemeanor
offenses when appropriate the health
care professional is not protected and
remains vulnerable when they are
treating patients and at this point I'd
like John to talk with the committee
about his experience and what other
security officers have witnessed in the
past few years thank you
thank you Paula uh good morning thank
you everybody for taking the time to
consider this legislation
so yes I'm John Patty I'm executive
director at Catholic Medical Center I'm
also a retired sergeant from the
Manchester Police Department I have over
22 years of experience there
so as executive director overseeing
security I'm aware of the reports of
assaults on our employees
on many occasions we would call the
police to report The Assault on a
HealthCare Employee only to be told by
the police that they would not make a
warrantless arrest but rather apply for
a warrant
I'm going to ask you imagine how
frightening it is for a healthcare
worker
who has just been assaulted by somebody
um to have to remain in that intimate
setting and still provide care
I heard domestic violence referenced
earlier part of the reason for the
change in that statute was to be able to
separate the assailant from the victim
the police are basing their decision not
to arrest
based on language in the current statute
under 594-10 which reads in part if not
immediately arrested such person will
cause further personal injury or damage
the property
this language essentially requires the
officer to predict future behavior of
the suspect in order to make a
warrantless arrest in my opinion not
making an arrest at that juncture places
the victim at risk of another assault
which essentially equates to a pattern
of abuse
with unique unique perspective of having
been on both sides of this issue I
wanted to amend the language to provide
police with more clarity in the statute
which would give them greater confidence
in making a warrantless arrest
while at the same time providing our
health care workers a measure of safety
and assurance and allowing victims of a
crime a sense of control and protection
there are current statutes that provide
the police the authority to make a
warrantless arrest for certain
misdemeanor level offenses and I'm
asking the same Authority be
specifically granted to police in the
case of assault against a health care
worker by a patient
if you're not aware assaults on
workplace assaults and workplace
violence and Health Care Facilities has
been increasing concern for health care
workers depending on the publication you
read stats indicate that health care
workers are four to five times more
likely than other Private Industry
employees to be victims of workplace
violence
there are many studies including some
from OSHA that show the prevalence of
assaults in these settings to support
that data
part of the work that went into this
bill last year focused on the need for
collecting relevant data to support the
need for a workplace violence prevention
program for healthcare facilities
throughout the state
this data will be used to support a
commission to review and analyze
Healthcare workplace violence and safety
issues that are affecting our health
care workers and organizations
when I began this process of trying to
have legislation pass to address this
concern which I consider it to be a
victims rights issue I began collecting
data from other New Hampshire hospitals
uh between January of 2020 and June of
2021 so 18 month period uh 13 of the 26
hospitals reported data to me
um
that indicated they had 671 assaults
during that 18-month period so you know
Senator gray
um
spoke to earlier seven hospitals that's
it just seven so five this year
um
through February is when I collected the
data
provided stats that show there were 50
assaults so far in our hospitals
uh just to address some of the prior
testimony if I could
there'd be no CMS risk for hospitals
for detaining a patient
um
who probably
six years ago now
um
I had come before
the Senate earlier to request
legislation for security health care
workers when after I retired from the
police department and went to work as
the Director of security at CMC and saw
what the security officers dealt with
I was amazed that there was no
protection for them in the statutes so I
had requested that some legislation be
passed and it was RSA 620 7 colon six
Roman numeral eight that gives them the
right to um
um
maintain decorum in the hospital is the
way that the language is written
um
could you repeat that statute again
please yes 627 colon six
Roman numeral Roman numeral eight
and the the issue of the Mental Health
crisis
is real
not minimizing that at all however you
know I I strongly feel that you know
victims of these crimes have rights too
and this is where this is coming from I
know as a police officer if I
was called to
um
an event involving somebody who is
having a mental health crisis and they
assaulted the police officer they would
be charged
that's a fact
so it's real it's okay that they'd be
charged you know we're not minimizing
their
crisis that they may be in
but it still doesn't give them the right
to assault others
thank you very much for hearing my
testimony
thank you could you explain to the
committee
who's going to make the determination
this situation who is suffering from a
mental health issue and who is just
being a criminal when when you have a
patient assaulting a health care worker
or security officer the police are
called they now have the power to arrest
who's going to make the call and once
they make the call where do they go with
the patient so yeah so different
considerations right not every assault
is committed by someone in a
Mental Health crisis however you know
the statute reads that you know when a
person is IE8 you know involuntarily
they're brought to a hospital for a
treatment right so then within 72 hours
they have to have a hearing on that so
if it's if they've been committed if
they are
in our care as a iea patient they've
been committed to the state so they are
not free to leave anyway right so they
would still be eligible for a bail
hearing but they're not going to be free
to leave that's you know one thing if
they're committed right they're
committed to the state for a reason and
they have to be uh you know they have
due process and they have to go through
their their hearing however there are
many many instances where our healthcare
workers are being assaulted by you know
patients who may be under the influence
of drugs right and you know that's a
consideration as well for
um
you know the community right but you
know they're not getting the same
um consideration as mental health
patients
right so we're not we're not minimizing
their actions just because they're under
the um
influence of drugs
so when we train new staff coming into
the hospital
I often pose this question to them I
said it because I was amazed quite
frankly not to be dramatic but to see
the behavior of
some patients in the hospital
it was stunning to me I was shocked so I
tell them I said you know in order to
make a determination how you should
handle this I said take that person's
behavior and move it to a restaurant on
Elm Street in Manchester right would
anybody put up with that no and they
shouldn't right the police would be
called and so the behavior that goes on
in the hospital is shocking
agreed but to my question who who makes
the determination at that moment this
person should go with the police to to
to be held or is a mental health patient
setting aside someone who's been
involuntary committed sure
so
any I think any Hospital any medical
provider would tell you that the patient
would have to be cleared medically first
right so if the person is not able to
medically cleared then that would be a
consideration for all parties right the
the doctor
the police you know the police still
have to do their investigation make sure
that there is probable cause to make the
arrest
um and then you know this is not a
mandatory arrest right so they still
have the right
to make that decision and not arrested
that time
however to your point it would be the
police and the health care worker making
that decision
representative chairman
thank you Mr chairman and this question
is for the person's security here
um
you've obviously been through the police
academy and you know that there's a lot
of time spent on use of force training
constitutional law criminal code the
different thresholds of evidence to
support a detainment or arrest
in how much time is spent on handcuffing
defensive tactics and restraint
um how much time do you spend with your
security officers in your hospital of
that same training
so we have uh 120 hours of
you know it's field training essentially
um and then we have
um three hour
use of force class to begin with before
that's part of their initial training
and then we have annual use of force
training uh similar to police
departments
follow up
and I know you can't speak to this maybe
the hospital Association can is that the
standard for all hospitals in the state
of New Hampshire
it is not the standard however part of
Senate Bill 459 last year will require
hospitals to provide training
to staff
representative pruning oh thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um the training aspect of the staff
whether not just the security staff at
the hospital but also all staff involved
in the hospital do they get training of
self-defense as well as de-escalation
training
so some hospitals provide it we do I
can't speak for all but again part of
Senate Bill 459 last year is that that
will be a requirement
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um I just wonder looking at
um uh SB 58 as amended by the Senate
um and then the floor amendment to uh
Senator rosenwald's floor Amendment
um are there one of those that you used
to think would is preferential and would
meet the needs of hospital staff as
opposed to the other or
um I'm just looking because I see there
are some differences and and uh they
certainly amend different statutes so
right right thank you for the question
representative Murphy um so as
representative Rose excuse me Senator
Rosenwald indicated
um the amendment
that did not pass the floor that was the
um the the language that was worked on
um as a during the study committee back
in 2021 and what was part of 459 last
year that did not go all the way through
it was pulled out on the floor of the
house and that's what resulted in Senate
bill 58. her Amendment
moves the reference of medically
necessary to the end of the sentence but
essentially her Amendment which is 1251
is what we worked on as she referenced
in her testimony with the stakeholders
what is what passed
um was a the floor amendment that
Senator Abbas actually Senator gray
introduced and that was what was
agreed to by some of the Senators and
what did pass 14 to 9 on the senate
floor so I would say
um as my testimony stated we this is a
very very important issue for us we are
happy to work with any and all of you
um to get to Yes
um but we can we could live with the
amended bill but I know not everyone
here that is going to testify is
supportive of this of this language for
various reasons
um we we believe it is a creative
approach to getting to the solution that
we're looking for or the goal but but to
be clear we worked on the original
language of Senate Bill 58 that's where
we kind of landed as the Healthcare
Community or the hospitals certainly
thank you so the floor Amendment uh the
senator rosenwald's floor amendment was
the one that was generally agreed to by
the stakeholders yes okay thank you
you're welcome
so you know further questions thank you
thank you very much
Holly Stevens
thank you good morning chair members of
the committee what I'm passing around is
my written testimony as well as the
written testimony of one of our Nami New
Hampshire members
um she was going to be here today but
the court is holding a session where
they're mapping mental the intersection
of mental health and criminal justice
and she was invited to that so
unfortunately she wasn't able to be here
today but I do have her written
testimony and may read part of that if
the uh if the committee would allow me
to
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is Holly Stevens I'm the
director of public policy at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
non-profit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy
on behalf of Nami New Hampshire I'm here
today to speak in opposition to Senate
Bill 58 relative to arrests without a
warrant while in the care of a medical
professional on the premises
of a residential care or health care
facility and I just wanted to let the
committee know that we did not testify
on this bill when it was in the Senate
because at that time we were one of the
stakeholders that worked on the language
and had agreed not to oppose it
um
as I mentioned by way of background for
the past two years Nami New Hampshire
has been involved with a stakeholder
group discussing the issue that is the
subject of Senate Bill 58 and was the
subject of a study committee the
committee to study workplace safety and
health care settings
at that time the stakeholders agreed a
statutory language regarding the use of
warrantless arrests in health care
settings that could be added to the
current warrantless arrest statute the
committee's final report contains the
language all stakeholders agreed to
which was also the language as Senate
Bill 58 as introduced and as you've seen
in the senator rosenwald's floor
Amendment
despite all stakeholders being in
agreement on this language Senate
Judiciary introduced an amendment that
no stakeholders were able to provide
input on as it was brought on the floor
of the Senate as you have heard earlier
today
this amendment makes changement changes
to the detainment statute allowing for
Hospital Personnel to detain a person
who is suspected suspected of committing
a misdemeanor assault
due to emergency room boarding the the
emergency room boarding crisis where
people in psychiatric crisis are waiting
for an inpatient bed for days to weeks
many times being held against their will
Senate Bill 58 will disproportionately
affect individuals experience a mental
health crisis and I know you've heard
from the the medical professionals that
they do not believe this would
disproportionately affect people in
Mental Health crisis but I think we also
heard Senator gray specifically say that
most of these assaults are being
committed by people who are either in
psychiatric crisis or there for
substance use disorder
recently Nami New Hampshire has heard
from six families whose loved ones have
been arrested while on an iea an
involuntary emergency admission in an
emergency room their stories are
heartbreaking and speak to Long waits in
the ER ranging from a few days to two
weeks while receiving little to no
treatment due to this several of the
families describe situations where their
loved ones many of whom are experiencing
symptoms of psychosis and don't know
what's going on
have become agitated resulting in the
hospital engaging in in a physical
restraint which which ends with the
patient assaulting a hospital staff or
destroying Hospital property
these loved ones were then brought to
the local County Jail where they
remained while waiting for a hospital
bed as you heard superintendent Henry
mentioned that this is often what
happens
if Senate Bill 58 as amended by the
Senate passes more and more individuals
and families will have to endure the
same result people experience in a
psychiatric crisis need treatment not
jail cell confinement
it is important to note that an officer
can arrest for a felony level offenses
you've heard earlier whether it was
observed by the officer or not therefore
we are on we are not talking about those
offenses rising to that level but only
misdemeanors it is Paramount that people
psychiatrically boarding in an emergency
room continue to have due process
protections afforded to them under the
law currently if Senate Bill 58 passes
people in a mental health crisis would
be brought to county jails for
misdemeanor offenses even if they are
completely calm when the police arrive
exacerbating the crisis that they are
experiencing and for these reasons Nami
New Hampshire opposes Senate bill 58.
I'm happy to take any questions what I
did
want if
if I have time I'd like to read a little
portion of her testimony or if the
committee prefers and I'll let the chair
let me know would you prefer that that
you read that or would you prefer
what you're speaking of you you did give
to us did give to you yes so we would
prefer instead of you actually reading
it if there's a certain you know if
there's like a bullet or two you would
like to highlight we're certainly
welcome to you're certainly welcome to
share that with us but we would ask that
you don't like read what you already
handed us yeah I wasn't going to read
the whole thing I was just I I'd like to
read her description of what it's like
to be in an emergency room for these
folks
if you've not been inside it I can share
about the yellow Paw the yellow pod is
um the place in Concord Hospital where
they hold psychiatric patients
there are a few about eight to nine or
so size windowless rooms with a door to
each and a bed nothing is allowed that
can be used to harm cell for others no
personal clothing pens or anything like
that
it is cold in there but everyone has to
deal with that you can sit lie down or
move about an aroma sign to you you're
supposed to keep quiet in there but it
is often stressful sounds people yelling
or crying and screaming and sometimes it
is somewhat more quiet only certain
staff are allowed in or out with a badge
who have the right to access it and at
times limited visitors it is only for
people deemed at imminent risk
themselves or others due to psychiatric
illness in the yellow pod you wear paper
scrubs and gripper socks the in your
monitor 24 7 by staff in the area who
does status evaluations and provide
transitional psychiatric nursing care to
the patients
there's also a common shower toilet
which patients can use which they are
escorted to and monitored during use she
goes on to talk about her son on day 13
becoming very agitated he was then
walking around his cell pacing it his
cell excuse me his room and pasting it
and doing kicks
um not hurting anybody not hurting
himself but the staff asked him to calm
down he couldn't calm down so they
attempted to put him in a four-point
restraint at which time he stepped very
hard on one of the security guards feet
he was then arrested and taken to jail
now I will answer any questions that you
may have
representative Prue did you have a
question
so
you know what I'm not gonna no
representative Newman
thank you
um my question is your preference your
opposed to the bill as it is right now
amended by the Senate and your
preference would be to have the original
language of the bill as amended by the
Rosenwald amendment is that correct well
let me be clear we were never in support
of this bill to begin with when we
worked with the stakeholders we agreed
not to oppose it
with the language that they brought
forward in Senate Bill 58 in the
language that was a part of Senate bill
I believe was 459 last year so we're not
in support of any language you know
requesting right now for this bill to be
itl'd
thank you
representative proof question I reframed
it in my head
so
I hear you're concerned
for the patients
how do you suggest we address the
concerns of the health care workers they
are still able to press charges and if
somebody is completely calm being
restrained by chemical restraints or by
physical restraints there's no reason
that a law enforcement officer cannot
leave the premises go get a warrant come
back with it and then rest arrest the
individual they don't need to be
arrested under a warrantless arrest
it's about the due process that's being
afforded the patients and so I would
argue that if somebody is being
chemically or physically restrained and
are no longer a threat to anybody in the
hospital that the officer can leave
go get the warrant and come back and
then arrest it if they're able to obtain
a warrant based on what they hear from
the hospital
do you know how long they can chemically
restrain them I don't that would be a
question for the hospital
so they could come out of that chemical
restraint and then act again while the
officer is off again they weren't is
that true
potentially yes yeah that's right they
could also act up again if they're
brought to the the county jail and are
then processed brought back to the
hospital because they still need
treatment and left there
representative Muse
thank you to to kind of sum up where we
are it sounds like
both versions of the bill
um are uh
objectionable uh to you uh but it sounds
like the original version of the bill is
less objectionable uh can you tell us
why that might be yeah we know we we do
not oppose Senator Rosen while Amendment
and that is because that Amendment still
affords the protections under the due
process where
you know
um I
I read the exact language
the the language that's contained here
there's also more language that
basically says that if there is a
continued threat that's when a
warrantless arrest can be done but if
there's not a continued threat if the
person is no longer a threat then that's
when the officer would have to actually
go get the warrant and come back so
that's the protection that's in the
Senate the Rosenwald amendment that is
not in the the current bill
thank you for clarifying it
representative mangaputi thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um so basically what Nami is saying is
protect the due process for people with
mental illness and this bill doesn't go
so far to make sure that protection
is available to the Mental Health crisis
people with Mental Health crisis versus
what is the threshold to be established
for the providers
it's a delicate balance so what is the
level that we can reach to protect the
people with mental illness and where
does that fall with the
Senator rosenwald's yeah we did reach
that agreement
um you know a couple of years ago and
that's why
um Senate Bill 459 was brought forward
and that's why Senate Bill 58 was
brought forward again this year
but yeah Senate the Senate Bill 58 as
introduced does afford the protections
that Nami New Hampshire thinks are
important for people who are boarding
psychiatrically in an emergency room
so you know further questions thank you
for your testimony
Miss nabel
I think I'm pronouncing that properly
Pam
thank you it's actually Pam DiNapoli
poor handwriting
um so my name is Pam DiNapoli I'm a
nurse and I represent the New Hampshire
Nurses Association which is a membership
organization of over 2 000 nurses and we
represent the 20 000 nurses in the state
I did submit my written testimony and
I'm not going to speak to that testimony
but essentially what I submitted was
results of a survey that we recently
conducted of emergency room Personnel in
the state to ask them about this bill
and overwhelmingly they were supportive
and so what I want to do now is just
kind of talk about some key points that
I'd really like to focus on number one
there is no federal legislation
currently that affords the same
protection against workplace violences
other Industries such as the airline
workers so we know that violence in
health care settings is only
intensifying and contributing factors
that I want to highlight
include work Workforce shortages which
aggravates a population that's already
aggravated so increased wait times
substance use and overall societal
tolerance of this Behavior this bill um
is focusing on misdemeanors so while
Health Care Professionals do have
protections against felonies not
misdemeanors one example of this is a
patient refuses a medication and the
nurse brings in the medication the
patient punches the nurse the nurse goes
to employee health the nurse is cleared
to go back to work she goes back to the
emergency department the same patient is
there and she's required to care for
that patient she's asked by security
does she want to press charges she says
yes the police come they do an
investigation and they say we have no
grounds to arrest this patient there are
no law legislation that prevents assault
against health care workers in this
situation we could issue a summons on
discharge so at that time the nurse now
is required to care for a patient who
has already punched her in the face
we hear a lot of opposition that this
says criminalizes behavior and I think
you heard testimony only that that
arrest is not required so the due
process is still guaranteed and then the
decision to make the arrest one thing
that hasn't been mentioned it may seem
irrelevant but is very relevant to us is
that currently in Vermont there's State
Bill 36 which is an act relating to
permitting an arrest without a warrant
for assault and threatens against health
care workers and disorderly conduct in
the health care facilities while this is
relevant is that many of our nurses from
New Hampshire work at Dartmouth and many
Vermont nurses work at Dartmouth which
is in New Hampshire so can you imagine
being a nurse who's working in New
Hampshire lives in Vermont who's covered
by this law but the patient can't be
arrested in New Hampshire and nurses
knowing that we have been trying to
advocate for this law for over eight
years so I think one of the words that
I've heard over and over is toolbox and
while this is not gonna it's not gonna
prevent the problem it's really going to
enhance the ability ability for us to
protect our health care workers which in
time the workplace shortage is really
relevant I think the other thing that I
want to say is that all of our nurses
are trained in de-escalation techniques
so de-escalation is not prevention it's
an intervention and what we want to do
is we want to think about prevention and
this act may be a deterrent so a patient
who is investigated by the police for
assault may think again about this and
and I do understand nami's position in
the position of the testimony around the
mentally ill but that's the population
that nurses are really trained to
de-escalate and deal with it's the
patient who just pops off because
they're mad that they had to wait 20
minutes to be seen in the emergency
department we can't predict that so um
in the behaviors that we can predict we
have interventions what we want to do is
to try to think about deterrence so
those are the important points that I
think are important to us as nurses in
the state so thank you for letting me
speak to the bill
thank you for your testimony
chair calls gosba cinet from the ACLU
Giles
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee it's nice to be here Jill
Bissonnet I'm the legal director at the
ACLU of New Hampshire
um we're here to testify against
uh the version of SB 58 that was amended
on the senate floor
and I could explain why but I do want a
flag as well that like Nami New
Hampshire we do not object
to the original version of sb58 as
introduced including the clarifying
language that Senator Rosenwald added so
no objections to that language we were
involved in negotiating that language so
I just wanted to be very clear but the
new version that is before uh this uh
this committee is something that we have
profound concerns about and I would like
to outline those
um but I do want to just just say a few
words about the history of of this this
has been we've this has been the product
of negotiation and discussion now for
almost two years and
um I think to get to that language that
we ultimately agree to took took a lot
of thinking and a lot of reflection
um particularly reflection with respect
to the real concerns that have been
raised by Hospital staff
um they're real these incidents are
certainly to to anyone who who visits a
doctor which is most folks or physician
or any type of hospital staff you know
it is concerning when hospital staff are
assaulted
but there are also some serious
interests on the other side right
including the ability to make sure that
due process exists due process insofar
as people aren't arrested without
um that are not needlessly arrested and
having their Liberty needlessly
restrained and of course the other
countervailing Interest being I think
our our general desire and the general
consensus that we shouldn't be
criminalizing mental illness that folks
need treatment they don't need they
don't need jail if they're going through
a particular crisis and I do think the
original version of SB 58
um
really reflects that balance and I'll
I'll explain why in a few minutes but I
also want to flag that the committee to
study workplace safety that is a product
of that negotiation I have attached to
my testimony as exhibit a so you can see
exactly you know what where the
committee landed
um two years ago and the language in SB
58 the original version is reflected in
that report
and of course that report among other
things also talks about the need for
de-escalation techniques and the need
for more data frankly on the degree to
which assaults are occurring in New
Hampshire there is a lack of data
anecdotes sure real incidents have
occurred sure but the degree in scale
how many of these are felony assaults
right how many of these involve
individuals are going through crisis I
don't think yet we have a good handle on
that information and that was in part
designed to be addressed in SB 459
passed last year which hasn't yet gone
into effect which will go into effect in
mid 2023 which is designed to address
some of that that data those data issues
so I my own view is before you strip
away some of the due process protections
and the warrantless arrest statute which
this which
the as amended version of sb58 would do
I think we should just let's see how
that bill unfolds with respect to the
data that we ultimately evaluate
um but as I said on the senate floor
um this compromise language was was
ultimately uh upended
um and the vital protection that was
removed in the original version of sb58
was the ability to conduct a warrantless
arrest really we're just talking about
misdemeanor arrests here and I'll
explain why but the ability to conduct
those arrests where there is actual or
threatened violence which I think is a
very important limitation the new
version that's before you strips away
that's that protection and that is the
core of my concerns and why I'm here
today because SB 58 as amended would
allow for a warrantless arrest for a
violation or misdemeanor offense in the
absence of any serious bodily injury
which is defined in law it's footnoted
in our testimony and also would allow
for a misdemeanor arrest with the
absence of any imminent threat to life
or property so I do want to say at the
outset when you look at our warrantless
arrest statute I've attached it to to my
testimony as well RSA 594 colon 10. it
allows for warrantless arrests
for offenses occurring outside the
officer's presence in in two situations
that I want to flag
the first is if there's serious bodily
injury because that would be a felony so
that's already covered under existing
law
now in the absence of serious bodily
injury what we're really talking about
here is is misdemeanor simple assault
a warrantless arrest can occur
um if without an arrest there's an
indication that that person will cause
further personal injury or damage to
property so I just want to submit that I
do not think it is completely accurate
that nothing can be done in these
situations that is the regime that we
currently have in law perhaps one of the
many solutions to this is just better
education with law enforcement of what
the parameters are for arrest and how
even with a misdemeanor simple assault
there still is the ability to conduct a
warrantless arrest again if you can show
or demonstrate by virtue of what was
said or the assault itself that there is
a likelihood that there could be future
personal injury or damage to property
and I know the concern well that's
that's predictive how do police officers
do that police officers respectfully
they do that all the time
um one example right is in the voluntary
emergency admissions context where law
enforcement and Health Care staff even
will make the prediction that that
person by virtue of what they have done
is likely in the future to be a danger
to themselves or others right so I think
this is this is part of the the general
law enforcement function already and of
course even without an arrest right law
enforcement can be present they can be
called and they can be there even in the
absence of a custodial arrest I know
obviously there are time limitations for
law enforcement but I just want a flag
that is still an option at the end of
the day
but the the the for misdemeanors the
language and current law that there can
only be a warrantless arrest if there's
likelihood of further personal injury
damage the property I just want to flag
that as a key civil liberties protection
at the end of the day to make sure that
people are not needlessly detained
because our view is you know if law
enforcement want to arrest someone there
should the crime either needs to be
without a war it needs to be really
serious Allah serious bodily injury or
um there needs to be a likelihood of
future injury or damage the compromise
in the original version of SB 58 struck
that that balance and it did so by
having the language that foreign arrests
to occur warrantless arrests there must
be actual or threatened violence while a
person is interfering in the provision
of medically necessary healthcare
services so you know maybe not perfect
to some but I felt like you know as an
ACLU lawyer as a civil libertarian like
you know that's that's close to
providing some of those due process
protections but while Wrecking
recognizing the very real concerns that
have have been raised here
and I uh the the second point I just
like to make is I know obviously there's
a lot has been said about you know we're
not trying to criminalize
mental illness that's not the point of
this you know I'm a lawyer so I look at
the text
that may not be the intent I think that
is what will happen here
um you know there's nothing in the
language of the text of this bill that
says you know a person can only be
arrested if they're medically clear
there's nothing in the text that says
um you know this isn't going to apply to
people going through Mental Health
crisis I mean at its core this would
allow for warrantless arrests for simple
assaults absent any indication of future
harm and I just want to flag what a
simple assault is this unprivileged
contact
that's what simple assaulted is in many
instances it can be severe to be sure
but in many instances it will not be
severe in what this bill allows is in in
all situations it provides as a tool the
ability of that person without any
indication of future harm to be pulled
out of the health care center set
setting and now funneled into the
criminal justice system and I know that
we know with emergency room boarding
being as prevalent as it is I do think
that it is very likely that it is that
subsection of individuals who are going
to be caught within the web of this new
particular regime
the last point I just want to make is
that unlike prior iterations of of this
bill this is kind of a unique regime in
that it is modifying a bill that deals
with Motion Picture theater owners and
Merchants
um which is I think very creative
um but this is very different the
hospital setting is very different from
Motion Picture theaters or from
um from Merchants so those statutes are
dealing with you know people kind of
sneaking their way into a movie theater
right or individual shoplifting we're
talking about Healthcare settings we're
talking about people who don't want to
flee or necessarily even evade they
they're there to get health care so I
just think the context is fundamentally
different and I think assault is
different than shoplifting I think it's
just it's harder to kind of the legal
permutations are just kind of
different but I also think what the
statute does too is give Hospital
workers themselves the ability to detain
which is you know pretty significant
increase in Authority I'm not sure that
was contemplated or that hospitals even
want that but I do want to flag that
particular issue in this particular in
this bill as well so with that I know I
spoke a lot but I just wanted to flag
these concerns again my recommendation
would be the original version of sb58
with the the caveats or the the small
modification that Senator Rosenwald
submitted we would have no objection to
that again because we were involved in
negotiating it thank you
representative Pro
I kind of have two things so
I hear you wanting to protect the civil
liberties of the patients what about the
civil liberties
of the health care workers it's okay for
them to get groped and and just beat up
a little bit no I'm asking a question oh
sorry sorry I didn't interrupt you no
you're okay
no it's absolutely inappropriate so and
they can't they can be arrested and they
should be arrested what we're talking
about here is a warrantless arrest right
so the point that I'm trying to make
here is whether someone is arrested on
the spot or not that person can't and
maybe even should be charged what this
bill is trying to get at is that kind of
X and GC of oh we need to we need to
immediately get in and extract that
person because there's an urgent harm
right if that's what we're trying to get
at the language of the bill needs to be
clear to specify that if we're going to
allow for a warrantless arrest there
needs to be exigency in the in SB 58 the
original version it was through actual
threatened or physical violence what
this bill does is it strips that away
right it allows for a warrantless arrest
even when there is no indicia reasonable
indicia that there is likely to be a
danger to property or a person in the
future and I think that to me is the
core and the balance that I'm trying to
strike here is
you know allowing for those arrests
without a warrant when there's exigency
um you know because that's critical I
think to protect Hospital safety but at
the same time trying to make sure people
aren't needlessly detained when there
isn't an exigency particularly when
we're dealing with a concern that those
people that may get swept up within this
regime are undergoing a mental health
crisis
I'm representative Hayden Phillips
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um Mr Bissonnet so I'm looking at the
original language of SB 58 before the
Senate Amendment took place and I'm just
going to ask you a little simple
question about the threshold that is now
reasonable grounds but before was
um probable cause and
what does that lowered threshold in your
opinion
um you know pose for
um you know the determination of whether
or not someone's actually violated
um you know any sort of
uh clause in the new law that might
cause them to be warrantlessly arrested
I'm just looking at the language beer
with you real quick representative
so the the the question has to do with
the the probable cause language
Pro that the the police officer has
probable cause and then going down on SB
58 as introduced that while in the care
of a medical professional
that the uh through actual or threatened
violence the person will interfere
that's the that's the problem so I I
don't I haven't viewed the probable
cause piece frankly as really a material
a material change that it is another way
of to some extent reframing existing law
but doing so in the context of Hospital
settings in particular in recognition of
the concerns that they raise that are
real and that have some data to to back
them up so I I don't think that standard
uh it is not something that has
concerned me because I haven't viewed it
as being
that much of a material change relative
to existing law I think the bottom
language in bold that is kind of the
material change that's designed to to
reflect the the concerns of healthcare
workers
thank you for your testimony thank you
Mr chairman
chair recognizes Michelle Dodd
okay good morning chairman Roy members
of the committee my name is Michelle
Dodd I'm the chief nursing officer for
Portsmouth Regional Hospital I come
before you today in support of Senate
bill 58. it's going to read I've also
passed out a short copy of my testimony
our team is comprised composed excuse me
of dedicated Health Care Professionals
who chose a career of service to our
community they proudly show up every day
to save lives and care for the patients
we serve the pandemic accelerated what
was a Workforce shortage into a
Workforce crisis in addition to that as
you've heard this morning over and over
again we now have a significant increase
in workplace violence that our teams
have to face in 2022 our facility alone
saw 58 employees physically injured
from trying to care for their patients
this year we've already had 13.
and to be clear these are not minor
injuries they are punched bitten
scratched choked have equipment thrown
at them
we had one employee who suffered
fractured orbital bones we have another
employee who has permanent hearing loss
from being hit in the head
we had one patient who injured six
employees in two days
and we had a medical patient who injured
two employees in in one day
and of course many of you have heard
from The Assault um our frisbee sister
Hospital of Richard Simo who
unfortunately died and that incident had
a very deep impact on all of us in our
community
as you've also heard this morning in
order to recruit and retain staff our
employees have to feel safe
they have to feel safe while they're
delivering the calm and empathetic care
that they show up to provide and
remember that as we rebuild this
Workforce our nurses our new graduates
they are young they're at the beginning
of their career and for them to come in
every day and have fear and and watch
these events happen and wonder is that
going to happen to me am I going to have
a permanent injury this young in my
career that's not okay
um this bill provides a critical tool in
our opinion to our law enforcement
Partners to support us with their
partnership we believe that we can
reduce the number and severity of
injuries to our staff and ultimately
create a safer environment for our
health care workers and our patients so
as such I ask you to support SB 58 I'm
happy to answer any questions
if I could um the incident you said
where the patient assaulted a number of
employees the same patient did
how would this statute have stopped that
was that person admitted how did that
come to be sure in that situation if
this statute was in place our partners
and police would have been able to as
you've heard this morning show up and
help us assess that situation I do want
to also add that I believe that as you
also heard from Dr Grossman that our
providers and our nurses Advocate very
strongly despite this for our patients
so I believe that they would partner
with that patient and help decide what's
best in this case they they couldn't
it's what you've heard this morning
there was nothing they could do because
they didn't witness it and so that
continued and continued and we were
limited our team was limited on what
they could do despite all the training
that we provide we we're certainly
compliant with the laws that have come
out and we had that in place before that
happened because that empowers our team
to be safe as safe as we can make them
but there's a lot that they can't do
that our police Partners can do to help
partner with us in that case in this
case this patient ultimately was taken
to jail but after many many injuries and
many many requests from all of us on the
admin team standing side by side with
our Frontline staff to include Dr
Grossman as you heard watching this
happen going please you've got to help
protect our staff
was that patient admitted why was he
there so long I guess sure he actually
was waiting for a psych placement in
this particular case he actually did
very very well for quite a long time and
then he had an incident with one of his
family members that he just snapped and
became quite violent towards everybody
and ultimately was taken
so was the involuntary commitment
procedure initiated against that patient
and does your hospital have a secure
facility to hold patients that are we do
have a pod in our ER if we need to yeah
in this case he could not have been with
any other patient that's how violent the
one patient was okay
representative salic thank you Mr chair
my question is very brief
um I'm curious whether you're speaking
in support of the bill it was as it was
originally written or as it was amended
we would support both
every testimony thank you
chair calls Karen Rosenberg
good morning I'm Karen Rosenberg from
the disability rights Center I'm the
policy director but I've been at the
organization previously as a staff
attorney for about almost 18 years
um and I'm here um to testify against SB
58 as amended by the Senate although I
understand we're for safety in our
health care is a Paramount importance
really I mean we want our clients to be
able to be safe when they get treatment
that means we need Workforce to be safe
but this bill does not solve that
problem and in fact it could make things
worse at our hospitals and I'm going to
talk to you about some of the situations
that we hear about because I think this
is about criminalizing Mental Health and
I also want to talk about some of the
what I'm handing out to you are two laws
of Federal Regulation which could be
Implement implicated if this should pass
as well as our state patient's Bill of
Rights which could also be implicated if
this bill should pass as amended
our office regularly hears from people
with mental illness who are facing
lengthy stays mostly at EDS who are
either i.ea in the process of being iea
you know involuntarily admitted due to
being in a mental health crisis
I've consulted with some of the staff
attorneys with my office to give you
some recent examples of how who these
people are and how their behaviors could
result in them being deferred to the
criminal justice system instead of
getting medically necessary Services
because remember what we're talking
about here are misdemeanor offenses that
would justify a warrantless arrest we're
not talking about a felony we're not
talking about them not getting arrested
at all but how it is that someone with
mental illness could end up in a
situation where they're diverted
unnecessarily to a county jail or to the
court
so one example I have is a woman who had
previously experienced numerous sexual
assaults and when she was brought into
the hospital generally what happens is
there's a a safety call from a neighbor
or a family member she was in a mental
health crisis the police come they cuff
her like they do with most people throw
her into the film not throw her but put
her into the back of a police cruiser
take her to a hospital that is really
not staffed to meet her needs her
clothing is removed her phone is removed
she isn't allowed to have no personal
objects at all she's put in a room with
nothing not a television not a book
nothing nothing to do to distract her
anyway so this particular person was
really really agitated
like I said history of sexual abuse by
men so you know she's thrashing and
screaming and hitting walls and
eventually a staff male staff comes in
to try to restrain her well this
exacerbated the situation for her so yes
she's flailing and makes contact with
that staff member person wasn't injured
seriously I don't even know if that
person suffered a bruise however if this
bill were to pass that would be
considered a simple assault that could
result in an arrest without a warrant
and trans you know and diversion from
treatment to court and to jail and all
of it another
um woman we heard about a lot someone
who they you know there's an iea in
place it had been granted she'd been
waiting boarding for about a week
um and involuntary medication was
authorized the medications delivered
intravenously and so this person called
us to report that in in administering
that medication what the nurse did was
like Ripper you know bottoms off and
shove the needle into her leg well her
reflexive action in that instance she
didn't want the medication again flail
this is how someone could get hit and
again that would be a simple assault
assuming the person didn't suffer a
serious this injury could result in a
warrantless arrest Interruption of
treatment transferred to a jail
transferred to court
um
you know we hear I mean repeatedly we've
heard about things like people who are
iea boarding you know experiencing a
crisis hearing voices not getting
treatment pacing and you know so that
we've heard about people banging their
heads against walls punching walls if a
staff member were to intervene to try to
prevent them from hurting themselves
it's well intentioned I mean you don't
want the patient to hurt themselves but
if they get in between the patient's
head and the wall and get bashed by the
patient again maybe the person doesn't
suffer a serious injury do we want that
person carded away to uh you know to a
jail to a to a judge to a court system
when really what they need is treatment
these are the kinds of things that we
hear about and that are really
concerning to us because in each of
these instances that I've described
those patients were if they were I I'm
not aware that they were even arrested
but if there was a need to arrest them
they could be arrested just not without
a warrant and their treatment wouldn't
have been interrupted
putting this aside however the other
thing that this bill does as amended is
that it deputizes people who work in
healthcare situations to physically
detain their patients even if those
patients aren't necessarily presenting a
danger
and this is very concerning one I think
in my colleague from the ACLU Jill
Bissonnet provided you with an excerpt
or maybe even the whole report that the
study committee came out with and one of
their primary findings was that before
that really de-escalation is Paramount
in terms of managing escalated behaviors
and so
encouraging doing anything to encourage
healthcare workers to physically detain
someone beyond the time when they
present an emergency or oppose a risk of
bodily harm to themselves or others
it's only going to escalate the
situation it's not going to de-escalate
the situation and so it you know it
thereby would then put healthcare
workers in Peril it also could implicate
Federal Regulation and our state law and
so that's what I handed out to you so
with respect to hospitals
um the centers for Medicare Medicaid
services CMS has a regulation that
provides conditions for approval to
receive medicare and medicaid patients
um payments and so I've provided that to
you and if you look at and that's um 42
CFR 42 13.
on page two of the document I gave you
it's highlighted it provides restrain or
seclusion may only be imposed to ensure
the immediate physical safety of the
patient a staff member or others and
must be discontinued at the earliest
possible time
so if Hospital Personnel were to
literally hold on to someone who they
suspected may have caused engaged in a
simple assault something that would
justify a warrantless arrest under this
bill Beyond and wait for them to a
police officer to come and the person's
calm That Could That Could implicate
their ability to secure Federal Medicaid
and Medicare reimbursement something is
really important obviously to the
financial stability of our health care
institutions
um now it should be noted that restraint
and seclusion are permitted when the
patient does
um present a risk of serous bodily harm
so it's not it's not that they can't do
that already they have the tools they
can do that but it needs to be stopped
as soon as that person no longer
presents a risk and we don't want I
think passing a law that would basically
incentivize in some way holding a
patient until they can be arrested
without a warrant is ill-advised
I also want to turn your attention to
New Hampshire's patients Bill of Rights
so I provided you with a copy of that
and if you go to page two I've
highlighted the portion on patients
rights with regard to restraint and
seclusion again similar to the federal
law now the federal law that I sent
provided only applies to hospitals New
Hampshire's patients Bill of Rights
applies to all Health Care Facilities
not just hospitals and what this
provides is that
patients are supposed to be free from
chemical and physical restraint except
when they're authorized in writing by a
physician now that can be a retroactive
authorization just to be clear but only
for a specific limited time necessary to
protect the patient or others from
injury
again once the risk is no longer present
those efforts need to cease failure to
do so is a violation of the patient's
rights under this law which are
enforceable in our courts so I also
provided you with the last page of that
document
um RSA 15130 is the section of our law
that provides that there is a right to
Equitable relief and damages for
violations of our patients Bill of
Rights
encouraging health care workers to hold
on to someone longer than necessary
potentially puts them in a situation
where they could run afoul of a
patient's rights under our patient's
Bill of Rights
so for all these reasons I think that
this effort is really not not advisable
our office also worked with
the stakeholders the law enforcement
ACLU Nami New Hampshire Hospital
Association on the bill as it was
introduced you know originally and we
were okay with it because what it did
was it made it clear that we're talking
about warrant the use of warrantless
arrest the concept of warrantless arrest
is insist in situations where there's
some edges exigency never say that word
and it's really to to say in a
misdemeanor kind of situation this is
what we're talking about misdemeanors
that where there's a likelihood that the
person's going to flee they're going to
destroy evidence and or as introduced in
this bill they're going to interfere
with the medically necessary treatment
of themselves or others
that's the kind of exception that GRC
could be okay with but as written now
there's none of that protection we're
deputizing Health Care Personnel to
exceed what they're permitted to do
under our state and in federal
regulations in some instances and I
don't think this is the solution to
protect our health care Workforce I'm
happy to take any questions
representative pru
ITT Zone never mind go skip
any further questions no further
questions from the committee you sure
you ain't got that one
okay
thank you for your testimony thank you
chair calls uh Mr Gary Apple
good morning Mr chairman uh members of
the committee my name is Gary app fell
I'm a lawyer practicing in private
practice in Lebanon New Hampshire
I am a member of the board of directors
of the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers and I appear
representing the association
preliminarily I would say that I know
that I'm in trouble when I'm on the same
side of a bill as the law enforcement
officer who's testified before me
so I say that somewhat in jest
this statute is well-intentioned but it
and I've been listening to the testimony
this morning it does not achieve the
results that the Senate sought
and it creates a host of new problems
that I want to bring to your attention
so I'd ask you to Envision the following
situation under the statute as it's
proposed to you
so a husband and wife are in a hospital
in the hallway they're arguing
uh a licensed nursing assistant
overhears and approaches
the L A doesn't know what the argument
was about
the LNA does not interview the husband
he knows nothing about The credibility
of either party
the wife says only I was threatened by
my husband before you showed up
and the LNA doesn't investigate whether
or not the wife has a motive to make a
false accusation
and then he arrests and physically
detains the husband
under the statute is proposed that would
be legal
it wouldn't be constitutional as I'll
talk about in a minute but it would be
legal under the statute
what this bill does is that it grants
powers of arrest that are denied to Law
Enforcement Officers pursuant to RSA 594
10.
um and I'd ask you to look at that
statute as you're considering your
deliberations
um and
um I suspect that representative pru in
particular will have questions for me
about that and I I hope to be able to
address them
it also uh so and if you if you look at
594 10
.
um it doesn't say that a warrantless
arrest is okay by law enforcement
officer for a criminal threatening case
I think you just heard attorney Rosen
well talk about uh accident
circumstances and that's important the
other thing is if you look at our
warrantless arrest statute it requires
probable cause which this detainment
statute does not require it only
requires what we would technically use
in in the criminal justice world is a
term of reasonable suspicion
with all respect have Mr Bissonnet um
and I I uh I mentioned this to him when
he finished testifying and he asked me
to clarify or explain when I testified
there's a huge difference between
Reasonable Suspicion and probable cause
so
what the founders of our country and in
general and and here in New Hampshire in
particular worried about was that in
colonial days that the king and his men
could arrest people and search them or
their possessions without a warrant and
without justification
so in both the State Constitution and
the Federal Constitution we have
requirements of
uh a warrant and a probable cause
determination made by made by a neutral
individual somebody who's not involved
in the situation
um and that was to protect
um
people
um from being hauled off to jail when
they there wasn't really just cause to
do that there had to be some some stop
Gap there it's just like we have grand
juries here in New Hampshire because we
don't want people forced to go to trial
on a felony when it's totally baseless
we have some various protections for
that
now obviously there are times when it
doesn't make sense to make someone wait
and go and get a warrant and that's
actually to the circumstances and we
already have in 594 10 an example of
that which is a domestic violence
situation within 12 hours of when the
act happened
and you certainly could as a legislature
put in that statute a similar provision
allowing for warrantless arrests under
certain circumstances for things that
are happening in hospitals
the statute here doesn't do that
indeed as it's written the health care
provider can detain someone and then the
officer still would not have Authority
Under the statute to arrest that person
without a warrant
so it doesn't achieve what it is that
folks I think are trying to get to here
which is the very real need that we need
to protect our health care providers but
this statute simply doesn't do that it
doesn't prevent people from being
charged from crime still if it's
appropriate to charge them and it
doesn't allow for their detention any
quicker ultimately by a law enforcement
officer
so we need to ask ourselves what are we
doing here
I would also note that while I hear from
the testimony today that Health Care
providers are getting more training that
may have been true in the past it is
inconceivable to me as someone who works
with police officers and with staff at
the house of correction at the prison
day in and day out that they have
anywhere near the same level of training
and experience as law enforcement
officers
those officers receive extensive
training before being allowed to make
arrest of Annie Stewart
as you heard from superintendent Henry
they trained for months at the police
academy
they work with field training officers
they have ongoing training and refresher
courses
Law Enforcement Officers also receive
another type of training that Healthcare
professionals do not receive
they are trained
in investigation and to make arrests no
arrest decisions that includes factual
investigation that includes credibility
determinations that includes training in
substantive law
it includes far more extensive training
and appropriate use of levels of force
and I suspect that even with current
training that it includes much more
training about de-escalation of
potential violence
what this bill does and it's not its
intent
but it legalizes vigilanteism
it encourages spur of the moment
decision making by non-professionals and
I mean Professionals in the sense of
Criminal Justice System not they're
obviously Professionals in the realm of
providing Health Care
and it allows the use of physical Force
without any required training at least
under the language of the statute
the bill also invites potential violence
individuals and I'm talking about
patients or family members or other
people who are in hospitals inevitably
will not recognize the arrest powers of
Health Care providers
some authorized detainers
um
any of these Health Care Providers may
use excessive force
because again they won't have the same
training and understand what that is
some authorized detainers may use or
threaten the use of weapons
and some individuals will seek and
receive aid from others to prevent
detention
you need only look at recent history of
the terrible results under somewhat
similar circumstances around this
country about citizens who are making
law enforcement decisions on their own
just in the past week there was a
shooting of a 16 year old Ralph yarl but
an 84 year old homeowner the homeowner
was clearly fearful for his own safety
whether that was justified or not the
court system will need to decide
but it was reinforced by a law
in Missouri that is basically a stand
your ground statute
if you look what happened in Georgia a
couple years ago with the murder of
Ahmad Aubry that was a runner who was
killed by men trying to stop someone who
they believed was engaged in
burglarizing homes
if you look what happened in Florida
with Trayvon Martin
he was killed at the hands of a zealous
neighborhood Watchman
the workplace violence that has been
talked about today is a huge problem
and I'm as much supportive of our Health
Care Professionals receiving the support
they need
I also sometimes my primary work is
doing criminal defense work but in my 34
years of practice I've represented
uh victims of crime I've represented
mentally ill people I represented Jane
Doe before the New Hampshire Supreme
Court last year with the involuntary
emergency admission case where she was
illegally detained at Dartmouth
Hitchcock for 21 days and only released
because they filed the habeas corpus
petition the Grafton County Superior
Court were not released but then sent to
the New Hampshire hospital where they
then had to go to court again to get her
out
so I'm really sensitive to the needs of
victims I'm sensitive to the needs of
mentally ill people
I know that when I was for six years a
member of the board of directors of the
disability rights Center we were
addressing these sorts of concerns as
well
um and we need our health care providers
to be safe but this doesn't make them
safe
it's it is unfortunately a feel-good
statute that is not going to de-escalate
the level of violence in in a society
that is far too drawn to violence and
anger
um and it's only going to make us less
safe it's non-constitutional and as the
language is written down now
um it will surely be struck down by the
Supreme Court
um I at this point I I would stop and
address any questions you might have
including if you want I don't want to go
too much longer I'm happy to explain
more about the difference between
Reasonable Suspicion and probable cause
if you want me to elaborate well I think
the committee is pretty aware of that
um representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted you to I wrote it
down here but I'm not sure I got it
right is the statute that you referenced
at the beginning of your testimony 594
colon 10. that is correct thank you
no
representative Newman
I just uh want to clarify people
mentioned the bill and so we have a bill
that was the original Bill and then we
have a bill that was amended by the as
amended by the Senate and then we have a
bill to be amended by a proposed
amendment that would take it back to the
exact original language of the bill
which of those bills are you for or
against yeah I'm afraid I have egg on my
face the only version of the bill I'm
aware of is the one that was on the
table this morning and that's the one
that when I became aware of it last week
that I made the decision to come here
and testify
so um that language
is uh it's really in section three and
it's an amendment to uh
the detainment statute uh 627 8A so just
just to clarify you don't have the other
information in so we'll have to
straighten that out and figure out which
this is thank you very much I don't and
I apologize for that but is the language
now just to be clear that I'm referring
to is about health care providers or
their agents being authorized to detain
people thank you very much
yes um and that situation as well but I
I don't see that as embolded language
was that already the law okay so
something else Yeah okay or it's a
different statue
um representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh I just want to ask
you a question about your earlier
testimony about the LNA scenario with
the husband and wife in the hallway and
as I'm reading this bill
it specifically says against a health
care provider or a patient actively
receiving treatment by a health care
provider so that scenario
would not happen that LNA would not be
justified in taking any action am I
correct I respectfully disagree so
someone comes in they're initially
screened they're told to wait so they
can get further care
um and they get in an argument while
they're waiting that that clearly would
be within the grounds of the statute and
certainly I know prosecutors who would
charge that
thank you did you have a question oh
sure yeah a question I've been waiting
so
do you actually think that that LNA has
the time to care about what that husband
and wife are arguing and first of all
they don't have arrest powers
right unless they're being attacked as
far as I can read through this
well so let me I think there's two parts
to that question so the first is
um that uh
do I think that an LNA has time right
and I would address that two ways
uh I certainly think that some people do
not but I do think that others do and if
there's a loud a verbal argument going
on in a hallway and the first person on
the scene happens to be an LNA that
person might get involved and I've
certainly had cases in my experience
where people are Good Samaritans and
trying to do what they can to be
involved so I think that that's possible
and more importantly you as a committee
and the uh the house as a legislative
body needs to be concerned about what
statutes authorize not just what is
likely to happen most of the time so you
should consider tightening up the
language
um because as it reads now it's too
broad and it invites those sorts of
things
the the second thing I would say is is
that
we can quibble about words about
detention versus arrest
but what we're talking about and if you
look at the both the United States
Supreme Court and the New Hampshire
Supreme Court's law on the law of
seizure because we make all these fine
line distinctions between seizure and
formal arrest
the point is it's a restriction on
someone's movement so that person's not
free to leave
and that has constitutional implications
and it needs to for all of us as
Citizens because we normally assume that
we can go about in our own way and do
what we want to do and now we're saying
that somebody else without personal
knowledge because that's the way the
statute reads without personal knowledge
can come and without doing a full
investigation without training detain
someone and prevent them from doing
anything so a police officer arrives at
which point the the police officer won't
have statutory Authority and will need
to release the person
that's crazy
um in your opinion if this were to pass
is written would not the employees at
that point become agents of the state
I I do think that's what happens yes
and would then liability incur on behalf
of the state or how do you see that that
would play out
um
so
I think that I'm way over my element to
talk about liability I have never bought
a lawsuit and I've never recovered a
dollar in Damages from anyone so because
I'm I was a public defender for 14 years
and and what I do now and I I about
liability principles I don't know I I do
think that let me let me interrupt you
I'm thinking more along the lines of
um liability in other words of a police
officer injures somebody in the course
of doing their Duty they're indemnified
as long as it was in good faith for the
most part whereas these folks injure
somebody are they are they criminally
liable I mean are they exempt from the
criminal laws at that point
well um it's going to come down to as
the language is put whether or not their
action was reasonable right
um so I certainly think you're going to
see litigation
um and my reasonable police officer or
reasonable hospital I mean what's the
standard that that would be that raises
a whole new area of law that's not it
absolutely because the statute doesn't
Define that at present I mean the
proposed language doesn't Define that it
just uses the word reasonable and and
the reason I I
I think it's important I mean what you
what you're saying is is key the
reasonablish language which I I presume
was taken from the you know the store
owner holding someone for shoplifting
um but but that language is is I'm
pretty sure drawn from a U.S Supreme
Court case Terry versus Ohio about when
a police officer can have an interaction
with someone that's short of a full
arrest I think that's different from
talking about reasonableness in the
context of self-defense so even though
it's the same word in the English
language it comes from different bodies
of Law and as presently it it's a mess
so you know further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you very much
there's anyone else who has not
testified in this bill would like to
testify
seeing none I hereby close to public
hearing
the committee will be in recess until 12
o'clock when we will take up the
executive sessions that are scheduled
and you're welcome I didn't ask all the
questions I wanted to
thank you
listen my tongue is bleeding so bad I
need stitches
I hate to see people get hurt
and how are you struggling
yeah
and
then
it's important question
okay
teaching you know and the emotional toll
and now as I think about sending my
child off to to college the
um
all the normal anxieties as a parent of
sending your kid away to be with someone
else are so much more exacerbated by
just the implications of all of this and
so I I support the motion
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair I too am in full
support of a felony
as we know not only our Our First
Responders put it at risk in situations
like this but emergency calls that come
in that those emergency responders
cannot respond to that you know it
really we're looking at so many lives
that are impacted and and I think some
of the examples people gave here
certainly speak to it so absolutely and
in full support
uh representative I'm sorry I don't see
your name tag but resin
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
relate a little story I worked in
special education for 10 years in the
Rochester school system and I worked
with a number of autistic children and
when I started their active shooter
drills were not a regular thing
but I'll tell you when I was in a room
with a single child with a room that did
not have a door in it but we had a
closet in the room and there was an
active shooter drill gets called off
it's much different than a fire alarm
you know we were having our fire drills
or found me walk the children out very
easily when I have to take that a child
who was severely autistic and put them
into a a dark closet very confining
closet and basically hold him in a bear
hug so he doesn't so that his screams
can't be heard
that is traumatic to that child this is
not a victimless crime even the drills
are criminal that what we do to these
children
when I got him out of that closet after
just 15 minutes in there the rest of the
day was impossible like his parents
worked so we couldn't send him home but
it was just nothing to do the kid was
hysterical for the rest of the day and
that was just one child I know a number
of other children in similar situations
throughout the state who go through the
same thing every time we have active
shooter drills
alone
and people have to understand this is a
serious crime and I will be supporting
it thank you
thank you representative Amanda Puti
thank you Mr chair
um for me it's personal in terms of my
husband is a public school teacher and
this is his second career and every time
I hear uh
false alarm and you know my first
immediate response is to pray and I hope
I see him alive coming back and for him
it is more how do we save the students I
don't have the ability to save my
students and whenever it's a false or in
the told the health toll it takes on the
teachers and the students is immense and
it's a long lasting
changes so I would be 100 behind it
thank you any further representative pru
I know from the first responder As A
Firefighter EMT uh
when we're responding to these things
we're already we jump it up to a higher
level because children are obviously
involved in maybe take chances that we
probably normally went to get there and
our job is now to go in with the police
as well so it's a whole different level
we're in a whole different mindset and
uh and
and it's happening way too often and
there needs to definitely be some kind
of deterrent to put an end to this
thank you representative wheeler thank
you Mr chairman it's personal for me as
well I uh pretty sure I'm the only
person on this committee who was just in
high school in these last five years and
I remember
um
and I remember very clearly
um you know being in middle school and
the these drills are getting
exponentially more uh common as I was in
school and we had many false reports in
conval when I was in school it happens a
decent amount not to this level all the
time but this level does happen we just
saw it in Portsmouth we just saw it in
our in our state and I I just remember
as representative grassy said how scary
the drills themselves were
um some of my friends worrying about
whether or not they get stuck in the
bathroom or get stuck in the hallway and
that's a reality that kids who are
educating should not have to face and
I'm not
a supporter of felonies or increasing
charges too often but this is a case in
which I really do feel that we need to
I've gone through it far too much and I
think that making a statement that this
is a felonious crime is uh the right
thing that the state should be doing and
I urge you all to support it
representative Muse
thank you Mr chair
um I'm going to support the motion
because this is not a victimless crime
this is an act of terrorism uh and it's
separate and distinct I think from a
genuine threat what we had in Portsmouth
last week uh was a young man who made
threats on social media
um police investigated and found that
those threats were borne out he had the
the weaponry and the ammunition in hand
to carry them out we're not talking
about that here what we're talking about
here is the worst kind of swatting
these are people who for one reason or
another decide that it's fun uh or uh it
it's some kind of a game to call police
departments and report an active shooter
and one of the things I just think we've
all seen from all of the news reports
from all of the recent incidents both
real and false is
how this entire situation
not only wears on teachers and students
and parents but also how it wears on
police officers who have to respond
and I think one of the things where
we're basically kind of coming to is
almost like a societal PTSD around
incidents like this so I think passing a
bill like this sends a message to people
who would try this or attempt it that
this is something we're going to take
seriously this isn't just a 17 year old
pulling a false fire alarm outside the
boys room in high school this is a crime
this is an act of terrorism and we're
going to treat it like one
thank you thank you and I'm heartened to
hear the um the bipartisan testimony
support of this bill I am hoping that
this committee will speak with one voice
and we will unanimously send this to the
floor and
um this committee and therefore this
state will be indicating that we will
not tolerate this kind of behavior with
that I would ask the temporary Clerk and
minority leader to call the rule
yes
okay
yay
shareables yes
the motion about to pass passes
unanimously 20-0 any objection to
consent see none the bill will go on
consent and with that I close the
executive session on SB 244.
I opened the executive session on
sb252 relative to defendant's pending
trial release this is um the bail Bill
I'm going to um I'm going to start by
saying at the beginning of this session
when I saw that we had a lot of these
bail bills coming in from different
sides of the aisle a lot of different
suggestions
um I realized that it was going to take
a little bit more work than just
Patchwork bills so I made a commitment
to this committee and to the public at
large that I would retain all those
bills and we would work on them over the
summer in a bipartisan fashion to come
up with something that we all could
agree on and I intend to
maintain that commitment so therefore on
House Bill 252 I make a motion to retain
that's why you're a second second
advice right
um
I'll just quickly add on to what I just
said when I speak to speak to the motion
um we have I believe four or five
different bail bills dealing with
different parts of the law dealing with
different issues in the law and we need
to look at those and look what's really
going on not take anecdotes not take
um
Panic measures on it we need to we have
level and cool heads when we look at it
as start of the process of looking into
it the first thing I discovered that is
causing some of the problem is that
police departments in different parts of
the states have no way of knowing
whether somebody's already on bail so a
lot of times the bail Commissioners are
getting a bad rap saying why are you
letting people out who are already on
bail well frankly we discovered there's
no way for them to know they were
already on bail that there's no
interconnection between them it's a
paper system so I was able to just under
the wire get the state police to get me
an estimate from their vendors and I was
able to get a million dollars into the
budget to fix that problem this year so
that's the first step that we're taking
and
I'm hopeful this summer The subcommittee
will come together and we will come up
with a good piece of legislation to to
fix anything else that we deem needs for
repairing representative gathright would
you like to speak to your second
any discussion on the retention
seeing none I'll ask the oh I'm sorry
representative Muse
I just wanted to say that I uh
appreciate the chair's efforts adding
the money to the budget to actually
address a systemic communication problem
between our court system and our police
is actually
a great example of the kind of things
that we need to be doing we have uh we
have systemic issues with the judicial
system that are manifesting them
themselves as uh a lot of the cases that
are coming up in anecdotes
um and I think as we hear testimony
we've heard that we don't have enough
prosecutors the prosecutors we do have
often don't have enough time to track
these cases in court we hear there are
issues with bail Commissioners not being
properly trained we hear that
magistrates might be a solution that
more judges may be be a solution I think
the one thing that's become really
apparent to us is that making
reflexive decisions on bills that are
that are very narrowly focused in this
area especially right now isn't going to
serve us particularly well so I I know I
welcome the opportunity to to really
take a look at this from a broader more
systemic perspective effective and and
to do it over the summer knowing that we
actually have a deadline to get
something done and that we need to act
on these bills
um but I I appreciate the opportunity to
do it in a
in a considered way where we're going to
be able to have the ongoing opportunity
to get additional input from
stakeholders throughout the process to
be able to test ideas with each other
and with different people I just think
that way we wind up with with better
laws and and it puts us in a better
position to fulfill our responsibilities
to the people of New Hampshire to to not
only to keep everybody safe but to make
sure that everybody's constitutional
rights are respected so again I I
appreciate the uh the retained motion
and I intend to vote for it thank you
thank you representative
um
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair and I also want to
thank the chair for
appropriating money for a data system
because I think it's very important that
whoever it is that makes the decision on
whether to Grant bail or not whether
it's a judge or a uh the mail
commissioner or a magistrate or whoever
it is it is has the appropriate
information in front of them so that
they can make an appropriate decision
based upon what the true facts are thank
you
see anyone else I'd ask the court to
call the rule
yes
yay
cheer votes yes the motion to retain
passes the bill is retained
and hereby close the executive session
on
um I forgot what number this is SB 252
um so for the committee at a
um SP 58 the subcommittee is the last
bill we have to act on except for oh
what's that oh I do have one more we
have to tell me to go anywhere
um the last bill we have to act on
that's still in play after today I'm
about to open executive session on SB 76
for like the fifth time I think
um I'm going to reopen it because it's
it was in recessed
um so as I said 58 will be the last one
until that'll be it for our work for the
summer except for subcommittee work so
the sooner we get 58 done the sooner
we're out of here for the the break so
at this point I'll open the executive
session on SB 76 and rep recognize
representative wheeler to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I'm motion
otpa on SB 76 uh
second and I I believe representative
wheeler is making a motion of ought to
pass and offering Amendment thank you
thank you representative Rhodes 2013
1432h
thank you would like to speak to your
motion representative
freshman of the high school right as
like like man you had said actually I am
a freshman at a high school that's right
um uh yes Mr chairman so SB 76 we've
done this five times because there was a
little bit of confusion from the public
testimony that was given uh people were
talking about two different statutes uh
the statute in here right as it stands
is an amendment to six RSA 644 colon
seven which amends the abuse of the
corpse statute and includes uh uh
failure to report the death of an
individual or finding a corpse to law
enforcement uh or unlawfully removing
concealing or destroying the corpse so
this is the bill as it should have been
uh and includes Maryland's law which is
uh the the name request that was given
to us
um by the woman who was testifying for
her grandmother who uh whose death
wasn't reported by the Sun so I no
further comment other than that thank
you representative Rhodes would you like
to speak to you second
thank you Mr chair representative
wheeler did a fantastic job and just to
clarify any confusion that may exist
we had to recess the last bill
um because we we actually had two
different amendments which we weren't
able to do and then we also discovered
that it was unfortunate the wording that
we had
was actually making it where if a if a
loved one witnessed a family member say
die in a hospital
they actually would have been guilty of
a crime had they chosen to call a family
member before reporting it either to you
know some in the hospital or to a police
officer so we we fixed all that and um
we kept it simple and I believe that
this is great the way that it is so I
would ask everybody to please support it
um I would ask everyone to support it
too because if I never see this bill
again it will be too soon
did they come around it went around
somewhere I didn't get it oh
thank you
that's all right
um any further discussion on the bill
again
okay
guilty
okay so the the motion now is to ought
to pass as amended and
um yes sir
yeah we do so actually you're right the
motion is to adopt the amendment number
um
-1432 and
um this
this vote right now is to adopt the
amendment
um and I would ask the clerk to call the
roll
if she's ready
yes
yes yes
yay
triple GS the emotions adopted
unanimously
um now it's open for further motion
representative wheeler do I hear further
motion
yes Mr chairman now I make a motion to
ought to pass with Amendment on SB 76.
as amended on SB 76 thank you
representative second second
um I think we've had enough discussion
if anyone want to talk about it no I
didn't think so
um wait a minute now you sure okay
um seeing no further discussion I would
ask the clerk to call the roll this is
now ought to pass with Amendment or as
amended or whatever he said that's
amended yes
yes yes
yes
oh it's actually hacking Phillips today
I think it's okay I vote Yes
um
yes
yes yay
terrible GS this Bill thank God has
passed unanimously any objection to
consent see none it's on consent
executive sessions closed and we are
complete for the day
um
what's that
no no no
hopefully there won't be one
um so we're done um you'll hear from me
on the next hearing date uh
foreign
subcommittees to all the retain bills
for the summer
um this there's a certain date the
speaker will let you know when you can
begin to work on uh retained bills you
can't do it right away so I'll let you
know when you can start
um I believe it's what is it like August
something like that yeah you'll have
from August to end of September but I
will uh
yeah he does yeah thank God
representative Rhodes wanted to address
something yes thank you Mr chairman I
would just like to take a few moments to
address
our uh bill that we have the
menstruation bill that that we that we
um
testified in front of the Senate
so during that testimony representative
Reed and I um had the opportunity to
testify together as a team
and the the version that we have
that unfortunately came out of here
without a recommendation I would like
for everybody to take a look at that and
there's actually a a couple of flaws
that are in there that weren't that
weren't even discovered when we were
here it was after the fact that is
actually making it where we really can't
actually pass it even on the floor is
there some grammical errors in in one of
them is it references the superintendent
as being in charge of the county the
state and of the the juvenile detention
center so that that is something and
another thing that has come up that is
not any of our faults but you know we
did not specifically put a number and we
were asked to do that for our version
which we did and now apparently the
other body doesn't seem to think that
they want the number in there so
good luck to us on the floor okay so the
version we passed out of here without
recommendation is still in play if I'm
not mistaken and we may need to do a
floor Amendment and see if we can come
together on it because the Senate
version looks like it might go down in
flames I think they're going to amend it
again I don't know just at the end of
the day I want to make sure we get a we
get a piece of legislation out to help
those people because that's what was
going on in terrific so so
yeah
representative Jennifer and there had
better not be a better conference on
this go it's not necessary it's really
they're making the whole thing is just
far more complicated than it needs to be
we address the issues the bill we have
is great
do you remember the bill number
no all right well I'll email the
committee both numbers so you can review
them both the House and Senate version
and we'll figure it out
yeah we made the amendment and we
presented it with the amendment
we'll see what they do all right with
that we're done for the day and watch
your emails I'll let you know when we
need to come back thank you
enjoy your vacations